on est face à une pénurie ya plus rien à
manger pas ce qui se passe c'est que les
villageois font grève parce qu'ils ont
appris que la reine du sud c'est le cas
les dragons etc est très très très très
bonne en gros elle aurait libéré des
esclaves et du coup c'est la révolution
les villageois vous fournir de plus rien
à bouffer heureusement que ma petite
pige veut dire ouais c'est vrai manger
les compagnons je vous laisse pas part
[Musique]
doudou c'est la grève nous et nous voilà
ce qu'on voudrait que c'est eux
on va pas décider les uns et les autres
non non non ça c'était nous on veut
décider de chacun et tout ce qu'il veut
dans le dans le maine pour être ensemble
voilà c'est ça la nouvelle idée qu'on
voudrait faire et la crise ils parlent
comme des [__] mais leur terrible
secret c'est que c'est vraiment n'est qu
on veut plus les rois on veut plus les
gens qui disent alors oui voilà ondes et
les gens qui disent oui à tous les gens
est ce qu'il faut faire par tous les
autres gens 1
alors ce qu'ils veulent c'est une
démocratie participative la vie
associative
c'est vrai qu'on n'aime pas trop
travailler dans les champs nous ce qu'on
préfère c'est boire du vin devant des
feux de cheminée on veut voter pour le
jean qui sera la personne qui est là
décisionnaire au milieu et vous avez un
candidat haqqani ok donc ils n'ont pas
de candidat très bien noble peuple
acceptant votre demande d'élire un
nouveau chef en échange de vos récoltes
merci le v6 un rien pas un parent ou
sarthois yeux doux voilà super je suis
hyper déçue que j'ai toujours été hyper
sympa et qui vu la joie mais bon
apparemment c'est pas comme ça qu'on
chérit nature
bon c'est la mer les villageois font
grève ils veulent ils y lire c'est ça il
va les lier un nouveau roi bon autant
vous dire un truc les copains si je suis
pas élu officiers tous à leurs yeux à
bouffer dépit passe et pourquoi pas
parce que c'est mon château en fait les
bons arguments
or pour que je vais lui j'ai réfléchi
fossoy déminage roma dehors ça c'est
morte
voilà soit les autres candidats soit 6
nuls moi je parle génial à côté cela
vous intervenez pour qu'on se présente
en tant que mauvais candidat exact voyez
vous même
[Musique]
137 villageoise villageois bonjour et
bienvenue à l'élection du seigneur de
ses terres mesdames et messieurs
veuillez accueillir les candidats
si vous votez pour moi j'augmente les
impôts de 70%
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire les
soussous beaucoup pour nous si je suis
élu je ferai en sorte que les femmes est
exactement les mêmes droits que les
hommes si je suis élu j'interdirais les
sandwichs je donnerai le droit de vote
aux femmes interdirait les promenades la
joie de vivre et l'utilisation des
routes j'ai rencontré ma femme sur une
route
et si je suis élu je ferai exactement
tout pareil que maintenant est le
changement c'est pas ma soeur
j'ai gagné c'est fort allez bisous voilà
la politique c'est pas si compliqué et
je suis toujours en course pour le trône
[Musique]